thought to on now so Patrick valance the
UK government's chief scientific adviser
a very good morning to you look first
and foremost what is your assessment of
where we stand this morning well let me
start by just saying I offer my sincere
condolences to the relatives and friends
of the unfortunate patient who died
where are we now we've got more cases in
the UK we expect to get more this is the
start of an outbreak clearly we have
cases across Europe across the world
this is a global epidemic and we would
expect to see more cases in the UK what
does that mean I mean what sort of
numbers are there must be there must be
analysis projections that have been put
into place by the government on this
what sort of figures are we looking at
yes so we've been looking at this right
from the outset we've had mathematical
modelers experts in epidemiology looking
at it and we've got a reasonable
worst-case scenario which is which is
looking at the the situation that could
evolve in the worst worst outcome
reasonable worst outcome and that
involves large numbers of people 80% of
the population getting some sort of
infection and as we've said we think the
mortality rate is 1% or lower of course
that's the reason worst case now there's
a planning situation I expect it to be
less than that and so does the chief
medical officer and the reasons for that
is if you look at what's happened in
Wuhan it's not 80 percent of the
population that's been infected it's a
much lower number and we think that the
mortality rate as I say is under 1% so
we do expect significant increases we
can't predict exactly how this will go
in the UK and we're doing everything
that we need to at the moment to try to
contain and are preparing to move to the
delay phase and the delay phase is
important because what that means is
trying to suppress the peak so we
haven't got so many patients getting it
all of one time and if possible move it
a bit so that we move more into the
summer months where the NHS is obviously
better able to cope and other
respiratory viruses circulating tend to
be a bit less in terms of this four
stage play
it was only announced on Monday control
seems to have disappeared relatively
quickly was this not introduced quickly
enough oh I think no we've been very
careful on timing and contain is still
where we are we are looking cases or
isolated there's contact tracing going
on and of course these aren't absolutely
discrete phases that go from ones or the
other abruptly you merge into them and
preparation for delay is well underway
and the key thing is that we need to
take the actions to protect ourselves
and make sure that we take action to
look after everybody and particularly
the vulnerable you talk about moving
into delay phase what does that actually
n tale for me not only governments for
institutions but what do we need to do
as individuals well as individuals the
advice is very clear and it's simple and
it's about looking after yourself and
making sure that we do things that also
protect everybody and that's hand
washing very very important very simple
and also for those who have got the
right travel connections and have got
symptoms it's about rapid staying at
home isolating yourself at home and
making sure that you call one-one-one
and get into the right system there
those are the simple things that can be
done when we move to another situation
as other countries are now doing in
terms of delay the things that you might
look at and it's in the plan that's been
published include measures such as
getting a wider diagnostic criteria to
ask more people to stay at home if they
get symptoms to looking at things like
school closures mass gatherings and so
on but there are other things you do
first and the key thing is during any
progression to think about protecting
the vulnerable
first and foremost so there are some
simple things that can be done there are
some more complicated things we're
modeling all of those and we'll base it
on scientific evidence
how does self isolation work because
you've heard a lot of a lot about it
over the last few weeks and obviously
we're now being told that anyone coming
back from Italy really needs to be
considering self isolation
people don't live in a house on their
own I mean just self-isolation make a
difference he wouid be looking at
isolating a household well
self-isolation absolutely does make a
difference and it's a very key part of
what can be done and there's lots of
evidence to support that from other
epidemics and other outbreaks so self
isolation is really critical of course
there are then more extreme versions
when you think about households
isolating as well self isolation is
possible usually within houses means
that you stay in your room you get
things delivered to it and stay there
for 14 days household isolation between
the whole household that's obviously a
more extreme move again we're modeling
that we're looking at that in terms of
what the options might be and it's
important that these measures aren't
taken too early so it's difficult if you
go too early you ask people to do things
which aren't effective for too long by
which time it becomes difficult to get
the right motivation to do it if you do
it too late then obviously you've missed
the chance to make the big difference so
the timing of this is really really
important well can you put kovat 19 into
some sort of bracket for us because
there is a growing sense of panic I mean
globally but but but also in the UK and
some people taking some already some
some quite extreme measures some people
and perhaps older people or those with
with some sort of infirmity or or or
condition are really starting to worry
now what sort of context do we have to
look at kovat 19 in at the moment this
is obviously a growing respiratory
infection it's very infectious we know
that it's a sort of infectivity like flu
it's got a higher death rate than flu
and a higher burden of illness than flu
and so it's not like ordinary flu on the
other hand it's a million miles away
from things like Ebola which are
absolutely lethal at a very high level
we're talking about a potentially one
percent or lower
and I think probably lower mortality
rate and so it's more dangerous than flu
but for most people the vast majority of
people this will be a mild illness so
for 98 99 percent of people this is
going to be a mild illness for a smaller
number this can turn into a serious
pneumonia and for a smaller number again
this can lead to death particularly in
the elderly and those who have got other
coexisting medical problems in terms of
the modeling which you've talked a lot
about when are we looking at a peak of
this infection in the UK is that
possible to assess well it looks like
and and and you can sort of see this
from Luhan it takes about 12 weeks to
reach the peak and then maybe another 12
weeks to go away again you'd expect
about 95% of the cases in a nine week
period in the middle of that and you'd
expect about 50% of the cases in a three
week period in the middle of it so this
is quite a sharp peak and one of the
things that we want to do with any
further measures would be to try and
flatten the peak a bit and broaden it a
little bit and delay it a little bit but
those are the sorts of numbers in terms
of what we would expect in terms of
timelines